und zusammen ihrer fällt heute backen
wir einen schoko käsekuchen sieht
richtig gut aus gelb den käsekuchen
den haben wir heute zubereitet ihr könnt
ihn aber auch gerne einen tag vorher
zubereitet und dann einfach im
kühlschrank lagern und ich zeige euch
jetzt zuerst einmal die zutaten für den
mürbeteig denn damit geht's los für den
mürbeteig brauche ich 100 gramm zucker
200 gramm kalte butter 300 gramm mehl
eine prise salz etwas vanille extrakt
und 1 1
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die kalte
butter und schmutzig geruch in stücke
da kommt jetzt der zucker mit dazu jetzt
kann aus butter und zucker einfach kurz
verrühren
hier gebe ich jetzt noch das alles mit
dazu und etwas von den extrakt und dann
natürlich auch das ei und beim apec ist
ganz wichtig dass die zutaten nur ganz
kurz verbunden werden
das reicht jetzt schon und jetzt nehme
ich noch das mehl ihr könnt jetzt ein
ganz normales weizenmehl verwenden
ich habe es heute einfach auf dinkelmehl
zurückgegriffen könnt ihr auch gerne
verwenden und das dinkelmehl werde ich
jetzt aber vorher 7 und dann die zutaten
einfach gut verbinden
jetzt hat sich der teig gut verbunden
und jetzt werde ich ihnen hier in eine
schüssel reinlegen und kurz abdecken und
dann für eine halbe stunde kühl stellen
da ist jetzt gut durch gekürt und jetzt
nehme ich immer so kleine portionen
ich habe jetzt hier einen wackeren
bereits auf 26 cm durchmesser
eingestellten auf dauer folie und auf
ein perfektes backblech gesetzt und
jetzt nehme ich diese schlange und
drückt sie hier am rand fest so dass ein
etwa vier zentimeter hoher rand entsteht
wenn ihr den rand dann so ungefähr habt
dann neben dir einfach die restlichen
teig gucken und drückt sie flach auf den
boden
also auf den boden nicht auf den ich
denke ich mir manchmal wenn ich ein buch
oder blog berichte schreibt wissen die
welchen boden ich meine
wenn der teig dann schön gleichmäßig ist
nehmt ihr eine gabel und sticht ihn
einfach mehrmals ein
so bleibt er beim backen schön flach
jetzt wird der teig im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 15 minuten vorgebacken und in
der zwischenzeit zeige ich euch schon
mal die zutaten für die füllung für die
füllung brauche ich 125 gramm weiche
butter 200 gramm zucker 500 gramm
magerquark 300 gramm frischkäse im
doppel raum stufe 40 gramm stärke etwas
vanille extrakt fünf eier 240 compaq und
eine unbehandelte zitrone zuerst nämlich
jetzt die weiche butter und gibt sie in
eine rührschüssel rein und stabil jetzt
gemeinsam mit dem zucker etwa zwei bis
drei minuten cremig verrührt
jetzt ist die butter zucker masse cremig
und jetzt kann ich den quark den
frischkäse die stärke dass vanille
extrakt und die eier vorsichtig
einrühren
jetzt wird einmal eine helle käse
buchmesse und eine dunkle käsekuchen
masse zubereitet und dafür nehme ich
jetzt hier ein drittel von der masse weg
und gibt sie hier in eine kleine
schüssel
die hälfte des schwanz kommt jetzt zur
übrigen also zur hellen masse da kommt
auch gleich der zitronenschale abrieb
rhein und den restlichen schmandt dem
frühere jetzt hier mit dem kakaopulver
zu klump einfach nicht und die masse
kommt darin dass eine drittel mit rein
und damit es leichter führen könnte
könnte auch ein bisschen von der
käsekuchen masse einrühren und dann
vorsichtig in die masse unterheben
jetzt habe ich beide massen vorbereitet
die stelle ich kurz zur seite muss
nämlich noch auf den teig warten und
kann in der zwischenzeit einfach schon
mal aufräumen
so sieht jetzt der teig aus den habe ich
jetzt eben übrigen so ein bisschen flach
gedrückt da ging doch ein bisschen nach
oben aber das ist gar nicht schlimm
jetzt kommt zuerst einmal die dunkle
masse hinein ihr könnt sie auch wenn ihr
lust habt wie zebra muster machen also
einen löffel vom helm einen potenten so
vorsichtig verteilen
das war jetzt schon eine richtig leckere
tat aber wir sind noch nicht fertig
jetzt könnt ihr gerne gefrorene
himbeeren nehmen oder frische himbeeren
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel
kirschen nehmen oder andere früchte und
die jetzt hier drauf legen da habe ich
jetzt 200 gramm
und darüber verteile ich jetzt die helle
masse
und sonntag kuchen jetzt wieder zurück
in den ofen den habe ich jetzt bereits
auf 160 grad ober unterhitze
zurückgestellt da wir dafür eine stunde
gebacken und nach einer stunde mache ich
den ofen aus die tür auf und dann kann
er einfach abkühlen
der kuchen ist gebacken und komplett
abgekühlt und ich hatte ihnen jetzt auch
noch für eine stunde im kühlschrank
jetzt kann ich bereits den shops
herstellen das wird neckar nach
dafür nehme ich jetzt 50 gramm sahne die
lasse ich jetzt ganz kurz aufkochen
da gebe ich jetzt 20 gramm koks wird mir
dazu das sorgt dann dafür dass die
gamaschen glänzt und sobald das
kokosfett auch geschmolzen ist kann ich
den herd wieder ausschalten und jetzt
einfach noch 150 gramm zar peter
kuvertüre die ich bereits fein gehackt
habe noch einrühren und so lange rühren
bis sie geschmolzen ist
merkst du hier mal weiter rühren ok
während san mir jetzt noch weiter
berührt kann ich schon mal den kuchen
aus der v herauslösen und dann direkt
auf so einen torten ständer drauf geben
also der käsekuchen würde so schon
richtig gut schmecken aber ich denke mit
dem schocker kuss ist dann noch mal ein
stück besser
und jetzt müssen wir die torte noch in
den kühlschrank stellen
bis die ghanaer schon ein bisschen fest
ist und dann können wir sie probieren ok
kommst du lang anstehen wir die palette
die nicht scharf ist abschreckung
jetzt kann der kuchen angeschnitten und
probiert werden
murat ist leider noch nicht da daher
werde ich mich ab und denken für euch
probieren hier haben wir den leckeren
käse kuchen
das sieht hübsch aus
dass hier einmal die ansicht von innen
und jetzt probiere ich
sehr lecker vor allem ist er käsekuchen
nicht so süß und wirklich die dunkle
schokolade passt perfekt dazu
wenn ihr jetzt sagt ich mag einfach
keine zeit bitterschokolade nimmt sie
trotzdem
denn vollmilchschokolade ist immer ein
bisschen zu süß das steckt einfach zu
viel zucker drin
umso passt die kombination echt sehr gut
also hier unten habe ich ja den zarten
lande schoko schicht dann die in bern
die haben auch diese knackigen kerne mit
dabei als die finde ich auch richtig
lecker und vor allem die zitronenschale
in der hellen schicht das macht wirklich
komplett alles aus und ich lege euch
diesen kuchen wirklich sehr ans herz
probiert ihn mal aus das rezept könnt
ihr nachlesen auch cds - blog.de
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei
und wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten
mal bis dann tschüss